if we choose to collapse one reality the
other will be forced into existence you
cannot possibly begin to understand what
you're about witness I give you a rock a
quantum connection with the human mind
what is that check it out we've
connected this guy's brain activity to
another guy in San Jose three two one
fire
you had no choice his fingers under the
control of living that brain I have
faith in you faith in your work your
body's still strong just a nervous
ascetic we can help you get your body
back
spark it up
it works are you getting this now
these are all my moves you didn't just
connect they'll tear you connected all
of us this kind of stuff I want more we
could do everyone know someone has to
stay off the system
give the word I will connect all not
spirits three
what did you do I must ask you not to
interfere
first I found it hard to control
but now an unexpected pleasure
single unified field connecting
everything
this is wrong on all kinds of wrong
this is just the beginning
[Music]
you